after seven grueling rounds the world's  top players came into the day desperate  to move up the leaderboard Chinese  number one ding Liren tried to confuse  the Frenchman Maxine Bashir lagrave but  the world number two came up with a  fantastic novelty and quickly steered  the game towards a draw kara nakamura  tried to play solidly with black against  Levon Aronian but a few critical  mistakes by the American caused him to  crash and burn as a happy uronian  vaulted into a tie for second place  tournament leader wesley so traded down  into a quiet draw against his countrymen  fabiano caruana but that decision may  prove costly as no less than six players  could catch or pass him it's all on the  line as the best chess players on the  planet battle it out to see who will  reign as king of the hill exciting final  round action starts right now